avec Gill manuel Vals on va revenir bien
sûr sur tout sur tout ce qui se passe
actuellement je sais que vous revenez
d'une visite en Israël là vous venez de
vous venez de revenir je suis revenu
hier soir exactement on va voir des
images vous étiez là-bas qu'est-ce que
pourquoi pourquoi ilê vous alleer je
suis allé dans le cadre d'une délégation
où il y avait des parlementaires
français parce que je suis un ami
d'Israël parce que je me rends dans ce
pays depuis l'âge de 20 temps et parce
que je voulais d'abord leur témoigner
mon soutien ma solidarité à l'État au
peuple à une démocratie la seule de la
région ensuite parce que je voulais
constater sur le terrain qu'est-ce qui
s'était
passé je me je savais que ça allait être
difficile j'ai vécu et j'ai vu et j'ai
entendu des choses insupportables et je
suis revenu je vous l'avoue très
franchement secouer et la troisème
raison c'était pour témoigner il y avait
une autre raison qui a été un
moment très difficile d'une extrême
émotion qui était la rencontre avec les
les familles de nos
compatriotes disparu je préfère
malheureusement je suis obligé
d'utiliser ce ce mot plutôt que que
prise en otage parce que pour le moment
il y a qu'une seule Française qui est
reconnue prise en otage plus de 48
heures
terrible mais je crois nécessaire et
utile parce que il faut il faut
témoigner et puis il faut expliquer
aussi
à nos à nos compatriotes ce qui se passe
et c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté Cyril
votre
invitation pour s'adresser peut-être
aussi à d'autres publics au public plus
jeune qui qui qui regardent beaucoup
l'information à travers vous ou sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment TikTok à quiil
faut essayer d'expliquer avec conviction
avec le plus d'équilibre possible le
fait que en Israël il y a une dizaine de
jours il y a eu une attaque terroriste
de la part d'une organisation
jihadiste
islamiste qui a tué des Juifs des civils
parce qu'ils étaient innocents et ce que
j'ai vu notamment dans un kibuts qui a
été attaqué les kibuts ce sont C c'est
vous le savez ces villages de
d'Israélien dans cette région du néev
ils ont été créés par des rescapés de la
Choa c'est des village où on vote à
gauche à 90
% fait que 3 4 % exactement il
travaillent la la terre il travaille
avec des Palestiniens qui viennent qui
venaient de de
Gaza ils sont plutôt en confiance et ils
ont été attaqués on a tué des
gens balle dans la tête pour des
vieillards on a tué des enfants devant
des parents on a tué des parents devant
des enfants on a décapité des soldats on
a décapité les enfants on a violé et on
a enlevé euh et c'est un crime contre
l'humanité et le choc est terrible en
Israël parce que euh c'est un état qui a
été créé précisément pour protéger les
Juifs des poogromes et de la Choa et là
ils ont eu le sentiment de vivre ce qu'
n'avaient jamais vécu depuis la création
de l'État d'Israël c'està-dire en 1948
euh ce pourquoi ils avaient créé cet
état donc le choc est terrible et et les
conséquences sont évidentes pour eux je
crois pour nous non seulement Israël a
le droit de se défendre mais il faut
éliminer euh le Hamas et toute sa
structure terroriste mais euh
aujourd'hui on le voit ce ceux qui
trinquent et on l'a vu hier avec euh cet
hôpital alors d'ailleurs il y a des
nouvelles hein sur l'hôpital puisque euh
sur l'hôpital qui a été euh bombardé euh
l'autorité palestinelle a réclamé une
une enquête de cours pénale
internationale pour faire la lumière sur
l'explosion meurtrière euh à l'hôpital
de Gaza qui a tué des dizaines voire des
centaines de personnes euh de civils
aussi euh malheureusement et c'était un
DRAM pour nous euh dans le même temps
euh apparemment
euh les et il y a des preuves qui disent
que ce serait peut-être un tir raté le
département de la Défense américain
affirme avoir des éléments disculpant
Israël est-ce que ça ça a été vérifié ou
pas g puisque j'ai vu aussi qu'edou
plinel a publié un tweet aujourd'hui
dans lequel il rapporte l'enquête du
Guardian qui conclut que le cratère sur
le parking de l'hôpital ne correspondait
pas à une attaque aérienne mais plutôt
un tir de roquette qui a échoué he c'est
ça oui oui oui ils ont fait des des
analyses si je puux dire du du trou de
bombe de ce qu'aurait été une bombe et
une attaque aérienne avec une bombe
aurait fait un cratère beaucoup ou plus
important donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
il faut rester prudent parce que c'est
vraiment une guerre de communication
avec de la manipulation mais aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que plutôt les témoignages
exonèrent une attaque aérienne
israélienne voilà alors Israël a accepté
l'aide humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza
les camions arriveront demain juste
manuel Val moi je vous pose toutes les
questions il y a beaucoup de de gens qui
qui réagissent en direct et qui disent
est-ce que vous êtes allz aussi en
Palestine également ou ou pas du tout il
se trouve que pour l'attentat voilà bien
sûr mais trouve que parce que je vous
dis toutes les questions qui tombent il
y en a énormément ça bien sûr d'abord il
faut dire quelque chose que la peine
d'une d'une maman palestinienne est la
même que celle d'une maman israélienne
la vie d'un homme d'une femme d'un
enfant c'est la même pour pour tout mais
mais
mais la symétrie des
souffrances n'est pas la symétrie des
responsabilités
je sais que c'est difficile à comprendre
surtout dans le monde des images des
fauches nouvelles et l'hôpital bombardé
à Gaza c'est sans doute soyons prudent
une fausse nouvelle et regardez la
conséquence regardez la conséquence de
cette fausse nouvelle parce que elle
enflamme elle enflamme Cyrile elle
enflamme la rue arabe et j'ai étonné
même que des médias français extrêmement
sérieux titent tout de suite
bombardement alors donc mais il y a il
faut pas mettre au même niveau je sais
que c'est difficile à comprendre ce qui
est un acte terroriste avec une seule
idée tuer les Juifs puisque l'idéologie
du du Hamas c'est non seulement la
disparition de l'État d'Israël mais
c'est la disparition de tous les Juifs
dans la la l'idéologie de l'islamisme
radical il y a d'abord et avant tout
l'antisémitisme et il faut le comprendre
pour comprendre aussi ce qui se passe
chez nous et il faut faire la différence
avec ce qui est une guerre et la réponse
légitime d'un état même si cette réponse
doit obéir au droit international donc
faisons bien la différence et je rajoute
un dernier élément je connais Gaza pour
répondre à votre question moi je me suis
rendu je sais pas 30 fois dans dans dans
ce territoire comme premier ministre ou
comme député évidemment je je suis
toujours ça pas été le cas cette fois-ci
ça n'était pas possible je suis allé à
ramala voir les autorités palestiniennes
j'étais maère d'une ville qui était
jumelée avec le camp populaire de
ranones qui est au sud de la bande de de
Gaza je je connais cette cette région et
et moi j'espère qu'il y aura un jour la
paix ah oui j'espère qu'il y aura la
paix j'étais ami j'étais ami de Shimon
Perez donc j'espère qu'il y aura la paix
et qu'il y aura de deux États mais là ce
que je veux dire avec beaucoup de force
et beaucoup de conviction c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une guerre entre Israël et
les Palestiniens c'est la guerre entre
un État démocratique qui a le droit de
se défendre et une organisation qui a
tué dans des conditions effrayantes je
dire et d'ailleurs on a tout de suite
voulu remettre en cause ce qui s'était
passé je reviens secouer parce que j'ai
vu j'ai entendu sir bien sûr mais parce
que j'ai vu aussi les vidéos et les
photos et j'ai parlé avec les soldats
qui sont rentrés et qui ont vu des
enfants décapités des femmes éventré des
familles entières décimées donc
ça c'est pas un bombardement là c'est
pas l'action d'une armée c'est pas les
dégâts comme on dit collatéraux non ça
ça peut arriver il faut faire très
attention d'ailleurs Israël est soumis
évidemment d'abord au regard de son
propre peuple du monde entier parce que
tout ce que fait Israël vous avez
remarqué et plus surveillé que pour
n'importe quel autre pays non là il
s'agit d'un acte avec une volonté
d'humilier de tuer j'étais à la morgue
tu es saisi par l'odeur évidemment de la
mort pourquoi on narrive pas savoir si
c'est ce sont des otages ou des ou des
ou des gens disparus mais parce que les
visages sont défigurés brûlé écrasé on
était avec deux familles de de de
franco-israéliens au début de la réunion
elles espérait que leur fille soit soit
soit vivante et prise en otage
malheureusement à la fin de la réunion
l'une d'entre elles a appris que la
fille avait disparu une autre le
lendemain un papa d'origine tunisienne
qui nous disait mais mais qu'est-ce qu'
elle a fait ma fille elle est allée
danser parce que non seulement dans ces
Kib boots c'est les kibots progressistes
mais à côté il y avait cette rêve parti
qui est cette Israël de
téaviv Gy friendly ouvert qui aime la
techno qui dansait là il dansait dans le
désert le lendemain les parents ont
appris que
elle était tuée et vous le savez dans la
tradition juive on essaie de voir le
corps impossible impossible de voir le
corps impossible tellement été martyrisé
donc ce sont des des barbares donc il
faut lutter contre ce terrorisme voilà
après vous avez été traumatisé par ce
que vous avez vu manuel traumatisé
marqué oui ému parce que
je ils m'ont dit les les parents qui
connaissent notre histoire notamment les
parents de ceux qui étaient dans la rêve
partie ils m'ont dit vous avez connu ça
vous avez dit un mot tout à l'heure
c'est le Bataclan oui oui oui bien sûr
c'est on s'est attaqué à une culture
c'est c'est ces gens qui travaillent la
terre où ces jeunes qui
dansaient on peut se dire on attaque des
soldats on attaque des policiers il y a
une certaine logique dans dans la
confrontation mais là c'est c'est la
volonté de de nuire de tuer de faire
peur ils ont réussi quelque chose hein
la société israélienne était
profondément divisé contre netanah là il
y a une unité d'une force incroyable
donc je suis revenu très marqué c'est
aussi pour cela au fond que je voulais y
aller parce que parce que sinon ce n'est
qu'une guerre d'image et hop on passe au
prochain au prochain sujet et je veux
dire mes à mes compatriotes et au plus
jeunes d'entre eux attention c'est un
sujet c'est un conflit très difficile
mais là encore une fois c'est le Hamas
qui pardon je prends une seconde hein le
Hamas est une organisation qui pour
arriver au pouvoir à liquider 4000
Palestiniens après les avoir torturé
membres du fata c'est-à-dire de
l'organisation de l'OLP qui chasse les
homosexuels qui vont se réfugier
d'ailleurs à Tel Aviv
qui évidemment couvre les femmes du voil
qui enrôle de force des enfants en les
formant à la haine c'est ça le Hamas
c'est une organisation terroriste
soutenue aussi par par l'Iran tout est
très difficile là-bas la la condition de
vie des Palestiniens est est terrible
j'étais dans un hôtel de dans dans un
hôpital de de Tel
Aviv il y avait dans cet hôtel il y a
peu trois petites filles palestiniennes
de Gaza qui étaient soigné dans cet
hôtel de tel av parce qu'elles avaient
le cancer moi je suis convaincu que que
les conditions pourraent être réunies
pour l'entente et pour la paix mais tant
que le Hamas n'aura pas été détruit la
paix ne sera pas possible parce qu'il
prennent en otage 2 millions de
Palestiniens à Gaza et parce qu'il
prennent en otage aussi l'Autorité
palestinienne qui est en S Jordanie donc
il faut en finir réellement
avecvec Hamas il y a beaucoup de
manifestation beaucoup de de de de
personnes qui prennent
aussi voilà qui qui qui qui prennent
position et qui disent voilà que
beaucoup de de de drapeau free Palestine
on a l'impression aussi que que les gens
et l'opinion publique et c'est bien
normal ils se disent euh il y a eu cet
attentat effroyable he catastrophique
voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est horrible
on on a pas les mots c'est un
traumatisme trumtisme pour la pour la
société israélienne et et et il y a ces
gens qui disent euh et qui qui voilà en
fait qui après cet attentat aussi euh se
disent qu'est-ce que font les
Palestiniens qui sont un peu au milieu
voilà avec le Hamas qui comme vous avait
dit euh est une organisation terroriste
qui euh qui malheureusement n'est pas la
solution pour eux et euh de l'autre côté
ils disent voilà ils sont un peu entre
deux feux et c'est vrai que aussi euh
enfin c'est enfin ils disent que voilà
tout ils vivent des moments très
difficiles et il y a eu un un
soulèvement aussi après cet attentat du
côté israélien bien entendu et du côté
aussi de de la de la communauté
internationale aussi euh pour pour la
Palestine comment vous expliquez ça non
mais là moi je peux comprendre la la
cause la défense des Palestiniens pour
qu'ils aient un état enfin on a eu tous
le sentiment d'un grand espoir au moment
d'Oslo c'estàdire désaccord avec la
poignée de main entre Rabine Arafat et
le président Clinton et le roi de de de
Jordanie oui on espère cette cette paix
moi ce que moi que j'espère c'est que
l'Autorité palestinienne qui aujourd'hui
est discrédité son son président à 88
ans la corruption
gangraine cette Autorité palestinienne
j'espère qu'ils trouveront la force et
des Israéliens de ce point de vue-là
doivent avoir un rôle positif pour
retrouver des représentants qui
permettent de nouveau la discussion et
la paix et j'espère que les pays aour
notamment la Jordanie et l'Égypte
joueront également le rôle je suis
persuadé que la communauté
internationale les États-Unis la France
l'Europe en tout cas joueront également
sur il faut offrir une perspective faut
offrir un espoir sinon c'est c'est
l'enfarmement et et des années de dureté
donc dooctrinement c'est quelqu'un a dit
avec un peu de cynisme mais je crois
partager cela si aujourd'hui on votait
de nouveau dans les territoire
palestinien sans doute que le Hamas
l'emporterait donc c'est terrible de
faire ce ce constat c'est pour ça qu'il
faut éliminer le Hamas faut éliminer le
hamass mais après il faut créer les
conditions en fin d'un dialogue et ça
sera difficile vous savez pour les
Israéliens dire ça ce que nous sommes en
train de dire c'est difficile à à
entendre tellement le le choc a été
violent c'est pour ça que tout ce qu'on
dit nous à son importance quand on dit
l'hôpital de Gaza c'est Israël la rue
s'enflamme dans les pays arabo musulmans
il y a déjà des condamnations chez nous
alors que aucune enquête a été menée que
je pas être macabre mais que peu de
cadavres ont été retrouvés alors
justement donc donc ça veut dire que là
il y a il y a quelque chose qui qui est
qui est dangereux donc faisons attention
parce que c'est inflammable aussi Cyril
chez nous selon l'agence de presse
française AFP le Hamas affirmé que 471
personnes avaient été tuées dans
l'explosion de l'hôpital de Gaza une
source de l'Union européenne a déclaré
que le nombre de morts était de 10 à 50
personnes au au total alors c'est énorme
bien entendu mais voilà ça été par que
c'est une roquette vous voyez le les
dégâts d'une roquette va pas rentrer
dans le détail c'est terrible moi j'en
ai vu pendant que jeis l'interview chez
vos confères de BFM sur une terrasse où
même quand on est arrivé en avion les
roquettes elles sont pulvérisé parce
qu'on appelle le dô de fer israélien
mais les dégâts ne sont pas de la même
nature ça peut faire des morts
une bombe israélienne sur un site précis
puisque aujourd'hui il bombarde là où il
y a des armes où il y a des dirigeants
du Hamas ça n'est pas le même ce n'est
pas le même effet bon donc tout ça ne
nous laissons pas manipuler par par ceux
qui veulent intensifier le conflit et
surtout qui veulent nous expliquer
pourquoi le Hamas c'est une organisation
légitime et de résistance qui est
insupportable évidemment à entendre
alors je voulais vous montrer cet
extrait du président de la République
qui a été interpulé par un jeune dans la
rue au sujet de interdiction des
manifestations de soutien à la Palestine
regardez la scène c'était en fin
d'après-midi regardez je vous donne ma
position en toute sincérité 1 je pense
qu'il y avait un délai de descence il y
avait une attaque terroriste c'était pas
bon après je regarde partout comment ça
se passe en Europe regardez dans toutes
les capitales où il y a des manif il y a
des éléments très durs qui arrivent et
qui font les les pires trucs c'estàdire
il y a des gens qui veulent
manifester de manière pacifique mais
dedans se greffe des éléments hyper
radicaux qui vont aller brûler des
drapeaux d'Israël
défendre le Hamas et ca est-ce qu'on a
envie de voir ça maintenant moi je pense
que on a plutôt envie de se regrouper
d'avoir une voix qui défend la paix
l'arrêt des hostilités la lutte contre
le terrorisme manière ciblée et le
respect des populations civiles c'est
beaucoup plus efficace que de se
déchirer BR d'ailleurs vous êtes
d'accord avec lui ou oui sur l'intention
évidemment moi je parfois je trouve
qu'on a la mémoire courte parce que je
je je me rappelle que en 2014 il y a eu
une manifestation à
Paris pour le Hamas qui allait de Dieu
donné jusqu'à Soral le néonazi en
passant par le NPA l'extrême gauche il y
avait la France insoumise et il y avait
les islamistes bon une manifestation
pour Gaza et pour le Hamas à l'époque
c'est la première fois depuis la
libération de cette manifestation qu'on
a crié mort aux Juifs avec des objectifs
clairs une synagogue rue de la Roquette
mon domicile qui n'était pas loin et
ensuite su de la rue des Rosiers donc
ces manifestations je sais ce qu'elles
vont charier je sais ce qu'elles vont
charier le droit de manifestation et le
droit de soutenir la cause palestinien
ça existe dans notre pays manquit plus
queon l'interdise mais nous savons
parfaitement aujourd'hui que ces
manifestations vont draîner ce type
d'individus donc le président de la
République a raison d'en appeler au bon
sens et à la responsabilité croyez-moi
j'ai un petit doute sur le fait qu'il
soit totalement entendu par un certain
nombre de personnes ou de groupes sur ce
sens des responsabilités on va parler
justement de ce groupe de la France
France insoumise la France insoumise
d'ailleurs qui a réagi tout de suite
bien sûr à au bombardement de l'hôpital
mais qui avait pas toutes les infos qui
a réagi voilà qui on voit Louis Boyard à
Gaza le massacre Contin continu
aujourd'hui c'est un hôpital qui a été
bombardé au moins 200 morts et des
milliers de blessés combien de morts
faudrat-il en plus pour que la France
appelle au cesser le feu bonb av la
jouissance bonbard un hôpital je n'ai
pas les mots Antoine léoman soutien et
solidarité alors il parce qu' au départ
il pensait voilà queon est on n pas
encore le les dernières conclusions de
l'enquête mais je vous dis même Edou
plinel aurait tout é que d'après les
premiers éléments ce serait ce serait ça
viendrait de ça viendrait pas de une
roquette ou d'un débris de roquette
voilà tiré par le dihad islamique donc
pas par Israël V ex devant tant de
silence sur ce qui se déroule à Gaza
donc Clémentine otin ce soir c'est un
hôpital bombardé au mépris du droit
humanitaire le plus élémentaire à 7
heure on parle d'au moins 500 morts on
voit que elle avait les les mauvais
chiffres et toute façon un mort est un
mort voil là on dit que c'est entre 10
et et 50 victimes c'est déjà énormissime
et là
sans morts euh qu'est-ce que vous pensez
500 civils innocents tués Mathilde Panau
l'armée israélienne a bombardé un
hôpital donc elle le met Mathilde Panau
alors que c'est a priori pas le cas euh
la France insoumise est-ce que ce sont
des gens qui sont qui qui sont dans dans
l'ignorance ou ce sont euh parce que là
on le voit encore ils sont encore mal
documentés il ils sont encore dans le
dans le buzz à tout prix euh est-ce que
la France insoumise aujourd'hui est un
danger pour euh la République revenir de
ces 2 jours je le fais hein en vous
répondant et et évoquer nos nos affaires
politiques euh bien sûr euh c'est c'est
intérieur c'est c'est on a le sentiment
franchement qu'il a a qu' a d'autres
sujets mais mais comme cette formationlà
euh a fait 22 % lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et qu'elle a des dizaines de
députés et que des gens les écoutent euh
toute prise de position de leur le part
évidemment lourde de
conséquen vous avez été bien bon mais
c'est votre rôle de présenter les choses
ainsi de manière extrêmement
factuel mais il y a une forme de
jouissance chez eux tout de suite à dire
ah c'est Israël enfin on va pouvoir les
accuser ça nous donne raison parce
qu'ils ont bien compris que leur
première réaction après les massacres en
Israël était insupportable du point de
vue politique et moral ne pas qualifier
le Hamas d'être une organ tion
terroriste euh confirmer de fauses
interventions parce que Madame pano a
confirmé aujourd'hui par un tweet le
fait que c'était Israël sans rien savoir
et en tout cas sans regarder du fait le
fait que les informations contraires
étaient aujourd'hui en train de de
confirmer plutôt que ça pouvait être une
roquette ou un débris de requette du
Djihad islamique est une faute morale et
en plus c'est dangereux ça participe de
l'excitation de la division des
fractures dans notre pays ils sont de
mon point de vue mais depuis longtemps
sortis du champ républicain c'est pour
cela mais c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui
que j'avais évoqué en son temps le fait
qu'il y avait de gauche irréconciliable
notamment sur ces sujets et à cause de
leur participation à la fameuse manif de
2014 que j'ai évoqué mais moi je suis
presque j'ai vu entendu là-bas et en
sachant aussi ce qui se passe dans notre
pays parce qu'au fond le Hamas on nous
le disait là-bas c'est d chez l'état
islamique vous savez que au lendemain du
13 novembre le président Hollande avait
ordonné le bombardement avec dans le
casre d'une coaltion internationale des
sites de l'État islamique araka et à
Moussou je m'étais rendu d'ailleurs en
Jordanie pour non seulement rencontrer
les réfugiés syriens mais pour aller
visiter nos soldats qui participaient de
ces opérations on bombardait une ville
on bombardait une ville en légitime
défense pour en finir avec l'État
islamique la guerre c'est pas jojo hein
c'est difficile il y a des victimes
civiles il y a des terroristes qui
s'abritent derrière les victimes civiles
parce que ce sont en plus des lâches qui
n'ont qui ne font rien pour le cause le
Hamas a été toujours contre les
négociations de paix puisque leur but
c'est la fin de l'État d'Israël donc
donner le sentiment que l'on soutient le
Hamas en refusant cette qualification
d'organisation terroriste de porter
l'attention que sur des accusations
fausses par rapport sur Israël c'est
criminel de la part de la France
insoumise c'est criminel c'est une faute
majeure et si le font en plus parce
qu'il croit que les musulmans de France
vont se solidariser de la cause
Palestine et vont palestinienne et vont
voter pour eux c'est encore pire on fait
un marché électoral sur sur la sur la
mort des gens sur des choses affreuses
qui se passent au Proche Orient c'est
insupportable je suis profondément
indigné merci manuel Vals d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup on va se
retrouver dans un